THANKFULLY NO SERIOUS INJURIES.
DAVID SPUNT, THANKS A LOT.
>> DAVID, YOU BET.
MIKE: CHICAGO MAYOR LIGHTFOOT
MAKING MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT FOR
GETTING CHILDREN BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM.
>> WE ARE HERE TO ANNOUNCE THE
VERY GOOD NEWS THAT OUR CHILDREN
WILL BE RETURNING TO IN-PERSON
LEARNING THIS WEEK.
MIKE: CHICAGO JUST ONE OF
EXAMPLE OF THE BATTLE BETWEEN
SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS UNIONS ON
HOW AND WHEN TO GET KIDS BACK
INTO THE CLASSROOMS.
FOR MORE DEMOCRATIC CHUCK
SCHUMER AND EDITORIAL JAMES
FREEMAN.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE.
MIKE: I WANT TO PLAY THIS VIDEO
OF DR. ROCHELLE.
>> SCHOOLS CAN SAFELY REOPEN AND
THAT THAT SAFE REOPENING DOES
NOT SUGGEST THAT TEACHERS NEED
TO BE VACCINATED IN ORDER TO
REOPEN SAFELY.
VACCINATION OF TEACHERS IS NOT A
PREREQUISITE FOR SAFE REOPENING
OF SCHOOLS.
MIKE: CHRIS, DID SHE GO OFF
SCRIPT OR WAS SHE JUST BEING
HONEST.
>> SHE’S BEING HONEST.
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY DON’T HAVE SCRIPTS LIKE
THEY DID IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
SO -- AND I THINK SHE’S 100%
RIGHT, OUR FIRST PRIORITY AS A
NATION SHOULD BE GETTING OUR
KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL.
HERE IN NEW YORK MOST DISTRICTS
ARE BACK TO SCHOOL AND HAVE BEEN
BACK SINCE SEPTEMBER.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS IN SOME URBAN AREAS
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO PROPERLY
SOCIAL DISTANCE IN THESE
CLASSROOMS AND I THINK WHAT
MAJOR LIGHTFOOT DID IN CHICAGO
WAS WORK WITH THE UNION TO COME
TO AN ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION TO GET
KIDS BACK IN THE CLASSROOM.
THAT SHOULD BE BEING DONE ACROSS
CLASSROOMS.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO DEVELOPMENT.
MIKE:MIKE: JAMES, YOUR THOUGHTS?
JAMES: THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SAYING THAT SOME SCHOOLS
SHOULDN’T HAVE TO REOPEN FOR
MONTHS, REALLY THEY NEVER SHOULD
HAVE CLOSED.
DR. VALENSKI IS EXPRESSING WHAT
THE SCIENCE TELLS US AND
COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SCHOOLS WERE NEVER THE SUPER
SPREADER EVENTS.
THE KIDS ARE OBVIOUSLY AT VERY
LITTLE RISK AND MOST OF THE
STAFF ARE AT LITTLE RISK.
MOST TEACHERS ARE NOT IN
HIGH-RISK CATEGORIES.
THE SCHOOLS SHOULD BE OPENED AND
EVERY DAY THEY ARE NOT, WE ARE
ROBBING THE KIDS OF THE SKILLS,
THE LEARNING THEY NEED TO EARN
IN THE FUTURE SO WE ARE
BASICALLY STEALING FROM THEIR
FUTURE EARNINGS EVERY DAY THAT
WE HAVE THEM OUT OF CLASS.
MIKE: CHRIS, A TENTATIVE DEAL IN
CHICAGO ANNOUNCED BY THE MAYOR,
ARE YOU HOPEFUL THIS IS A START
OF THE TREND OF SOME OF THE BIG
DISTRICTS GETTING CHILDREN BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I THINK IT TAKES LEADERSHIP
ON THE PART OF WHETHER IT’D BE A
MAJOR OR A GOVERNOR OR A SCHOOL
BOARD PRESIDENT TO WORK WITH
THEIR TEACHERS AND THEIR
TEACHERS UNION TO COME TO
ACCOMMODATIONS TO GET KIDS BACK
IN THE CLASSROOMS.
I THINK IT IS -- IT’S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
UNIONS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
NEGOTIATE AND FEEL SAFE AND THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT BUT
THE LEADERS OF THOSE DISTRICTS
ON THE OTHER SIDE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THEM AND WORK OUT A
DEAL JUST LIKE MAYOR LIGHTFOOT
IN CHICAGO AND CONGRATULATIONS
TO HER.
BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
OPEN, THOSE KIDS ARE GETTING A
BENEFIT THAT ARE REALLY TO THE
DETRIMENT OF KIDS WHO ARE NOT IN
CLASSROOMS AND I THINK IT’S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
MIKE: JAMES, I I WANT TO GET YOU
TO WEIGH IN THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
REDUCE ARREST, REDUCE
DEPORTATIONS AND KIND OF T TAKE
THE TEETH OUT OF ICE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
JAMES: WELL, WE WILL SEE.
I THINK PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
CONFUSED WATCHING THOSE DEBATES
LAST YEAR THINKING THAT THE
DIFFERENCE IN PRACTICE IN POLICY
TWINE BIDEN AND TRUMP
ADMINISTRATIONS IS BIGGER THAN
IT ACTUALLY IS.
BUT I THINK HE’S -- THE
PRESIDENT NOW, I THINK SHE’S
GOING TO FIND THAT YOU DO HAVE
TO ENFORCE A BORDER OR YOU
INVITE PEOPLE TO ATTEMPT TO
CROSS WHO ARE NOT COMING IN
LEGALLY.
NOW THAT HAVING BEEN SAID, I
WOULD HOPE THAT THE PRESIDENT
WILL NOW SEEK THE DEAL THAT
NANCY PELOSI NEVER REALLY WANTED
TO TRY WITH DONALD TRUMP, IS TO
GET BORDER ENFORCEMENT BUT ALSO
MORE LEGAL IMMIGRATION FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COME HERE AND
WORK AND BE PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS.